okay I guess we sort of have to talk
about Sarah Huckabee Sanders Donald
Trump's press secretary uh where to even
start with this on Monday we talked
Monday or Tuesday we talked about how
she gave her first press briefing in 41
days it was riddled with the same
non-answers deflections and blaming
Democrats that we've seen from her for a
very long time at this point and one of
the questions that I've asked more and
more about Sarah Huckabee Sanders is why
is she doing this because she's so
publicly lying just endlessly why has
she chosen to do this why does she work
for Trump at all but more importantly
why is she doing something so public she
could be pushing papers for the Trump
administration in some back office but
she's the front-and-center primary liar
who has to go out there and defend an
obfuscate for Donald Trump's benefit and
I floated a few different ideas about
why she may be doing this one
possibility is she gets paid really well
well we know what she gets paid and it's
a nice Whitehouse top-tier salary but
her father Mike Huckabee has somewhere
around 10 million dollars I don't think
that she has to be doing this job for
the money
and she could probably get another job
making a decent salary maybe not what
she makes working at the White House is
it possible that she is a religious
woman and as the daughter of a preacher
or whatever else Mike Huckabee is that
she believes that she is doing God's
work in some way that God has called her
to be press secretary of the United
States maybe now we're sort of starting
to get a little bit closer and it seems
that God is a big part of the
explanation because when you look back
and say wait a second why would a
so-called Christian be so willing to lie
and to distort and to attack reporters
and do everything that Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is doing unless she thinks the
big picture is that she's doing God's
work because Trump was appointed by God
for
example this was merely hypothetical
until now because Sarah Huckabee Sanders
was interviewed on one of the most
depraved television channels around
Christian Broadcasting Network and she
has confirmed that yes she believes God
wanted Donald Trump to be President take
a look I think God calls all of us to
fill different roles at different times
and I think that he wanted Donald Trump
to become president and that's why he's
there and I think he has done a
tremendous job and supporting a lot of
the things that people of faith really
care about exactly if it wasn't for God
Trump wouldn't be president that's a
very strange sense of humor for God
isn't it it wasn't Trump's foreign
policy
it wasn't Trump's trade ideas it wasn't
the implication that Mexicans are by and
large criminals although some Trump is
sure are good people
God just wanted Trump to be President of
the United States and that that's why
he's there and by extension that is why
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is also there
lying
day in and day out or every 41 days when
she actually does press briefings or
whatever the case may be so what I'm
wondering is is every American president
there because God wanted them to be
because if she believes that God wanted
Trump to be president doesn't it stand
to reason isn't it logically required
that God wanted President Obama to be
President twice rather than just once
except Pat we never hear them actually
mentioning that ever in fact we hear
Obama was the Antichrist or Obama is
Satan's or something like that well God
is an independent voter so back in the
90s he was a Democrat that's why he
pushed for Bill Clinton then in the you
know early 2000s he went Republican when
with George Bush then went back to
Democrat with Obama and now he's here
with Trump I guess God just can't make
up his mind which political party does
he support we may never know it changes
all the time and this sort of gets to
the absurdity of what I discussed with
Arian Foster yesterday which was
former NFL player Arian Foster said he I
never really understood when players say
that they were able that they won the
game because of god that who under what
circumstances is God sort of deciding
the outcome of individual NFL football
games along these same lines if you
believe God is picking presidents then
he's picking all of them right including
Barack Obama two times so this is also
crazy I want to zoom out from it a
little bit because there's an important
element to evangelicals here that I
think bears some examination
evangelicals among other Christians and
other religions but in the United States
evangelicals are some of the loudest
that do exactly what Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is doing they confuse or they
conflate what they want with God's will
I wanted Trump to be President of the
United States and I'm religious and
Trump is president so God wanted it
right I wanted to in the case of George
W Bush I wanted to go to Iraq and I'm a
born-again evangelical Christian so
clearly God told Bush to go into Iraq
it's a combination of a very particular
brand of religious delusion with egoism
in very specific proportions that get
you in your head to believing stuff like
this Trump is there because God wanted
him to be there self-interest is sort of
the focus of their morality and of
course it's ridiculous by its own merits
why would God want the adulteress
cheating lying criminal who was
pro-choice his entire life coming from
people out of money and conning people
out of money is well contractors
customers at Trump University if God is
involved in selecting presidents why on
earth would he pick one that goes so
directly against the gospel that Sarah
Huckabee Sanders claims to follow a
truly disgusting human being
Sarah Huckabee Sanders may be the worse
than the administration for her role in
the propaganda and our suspicion
were true she is willing to I would
guess go against what her religion
teaches her about lying and honesty and
all of that other stuff because she
believes that the broad strokes the big
picture is that God chose Trump to be
President and therefore her
participation in the administration is
in a literal sense godly it's disgusting
and these are the people that are in
charge these are the agenda setters
these are the people who decide they
have gatekeeping power to decide what we
know and what don't we know about what
President Trump is doing we're in real
trouble make sure you're following me on
instagram at david pakman and while
you're there follow the show on
instagram as well at david pakman show
today's show was sponsored in part by
double e which you can check out by
clicking the link underneath this video
it's a cryptocurrency investing in
trading platform that uses artificial
intelligence to trade Kryptos on your
behalf
getting started is really easy on the ee
website choose your preferred crypto
enter your wallet address bitcoin
litecoin etherium - bitcoin cash are all
options
ee says there will be more in the near
future minimum deposit is as low as
point zero zero for bitcoin which is
great if you want to test out the site
without making a major commitment
financially you can choose from many
different trading package options with
different timelines deposits or instant
payouts are processed within 24 hours on
weekdays with a minimum withdrawal of
only point zero zero two bitcoin
everything goes straight to your crypto
wallet address you can also make five to
fifteen percent commissions from w's
referral program you can easily make
payments track your daily interest track
your referral commissions by connecting
your telegram account to double e's
telegram bot which makes for an even
more streamlined experience on ee ee
says they protect all deposits with
daily updated DDoS protection and global
CDN acceleration ee says their goal is
to make crypto trading accessible for
Brij people even people with small
crypto holdings you can get started and
join thousands of other users by
clicking the link underneath this video
and as always this is not financial
advice everyone should understand that
there are inherent risks with any kind
of investing always do your own research
before using any method of trading or
investing in cryptocurrencies and never
invest more than you are willing to lose